i love joe frazier for so many reasons
number one
i love when he walked in and i would
tell him that he was the true champion
he was better than muhammad ali there's
the champ there he is still
big and strong joe beat up muhammad ali
many times but was robbed
the greatest fighter in the world joel
frazier you are the true champion of
course
greatest of all time joe frazier this is
the greatest boxer of all time
i don't care what anyone says this is
the real champion
the world champion uh the true champion
the true boxing champion of the world
yeah i've been saying all along all
these years the true champion
of those fights was joe frazier
that's right some guys would say oh no
no no don't say
he loved it he ate it up we're sitting
here with joe frazier the greatest
boxer of all time even greater than
muhammad ali
that's my opinion robin disagrees with
me there are many great boxers
and then robin would start saying that
joe no offense muhammad ali is the
champion you know everybody knows
joe frazier everybody remembers joe
frazier there are many heavyweight
champions
that very few people remember why do
they remember joe frazier
why it's because of muhammad ali no
that's wrong
do you believe what she's saying he's in
love with him i kill him that's why i
didn't remember that's right
me robin gonna fight that money he
didn't end my career
he fought after him
i think i'm gonna come back and love
robin i'm trying to it was joe
when ali was still fighting big
where was who where was joe ollie was
still fighting in fact
didn't he fight george foreman
yes after george took care of you
yes yes he did he was still around to
clean up the work that you left undone
how come you know so much about the lord
guys
yeah yeah joe's going to punch right
through that glass
defensive smoke um you know he's the
greatest fighter
yeah exactly of course exactly joe knows
i love him i just do this
no problem
and joe again hit the way he speaks
he's so opinionated
did he win those fights or do you think
they gave him those fights because
because he was the great muhammad ali he
brought up the ring
do you think do you think he paid off
the judges he brought up the ring
he'd come in one day and say geez i was
mowing my lawn
and i ran over my big toe and i and i
cut my whole toe off i don't have a big
toe anymore
and you know you're like oh joe frazier
this great box he's mowing his own lawn
and now he's taking the lawnmower and he
cut off his toe
and he's talking about cutting off his
toe like it was nothing were you wearing
shoes
boots you were wearing boots and it took
the toe even in the boots
that's a good laundry did you scream did
you cry
did you cry cry what kind of lawn mower
was it i'm curious i don't know
what kind of wood there's a steel tip
boots you wear right
cut it right off wow boom and you just
wrapped it in a towel
and you even poured what alcohol on it
wow you don't have that much butter to
pick up the top
and you and you saw the toe laying on
the ground and you said i don't even
want it no
the toe was in the ground the toe was on
the booth hanging off
it was hanging off the boat and didn't
you
and you didn't pack it in ice no no ice
alcohol
and
and i drove to the hospital like
probably 20 miles
were you cursing when you when you took
your toe off or you didn't even care
no no problem can we see can we see what
your foot looks like
really let me see that let me see i got
to see it champ got some design
socks very nice let me see what happened
to the champ
whoa let me see it oh no it's gone oh
man oh champ the whole damn toe is gone
the champ's toe is gone that was joe
frazier
one of the greats great talk show guest
and great boxer you know the last time
you were here yeah you uh
loved robin so much oh man well for a
while
he got very cold to me because he found
out that i was a muhammad ali fan and
then he got very angry
you love robin so much last thing we
hear you saying that beautiful song to
her
it's so good loving
somebody when somebody loves you back
girl that's the fact to be loved
and love in return is the only thing my
heart desire
to appreciate the little things i do
oh you're the one that got me inspired
keep on lifting me look at me
[Applause]
oh